tu es tellement de confidences de femmes
par exemple qui me disent bah écoute mon
mari m'a trompé parce que ça ne va plus
on y est c'est vrai que en fait on n'en
parle pas assez et surtout qu'on vous
propose pas assez de produits naturels
qui pourrait vous aider faut savoir et
les meufs que déjà je vais vous montrer
les produits donc là c'est des capsules
de resserrement intime donc c'est assez
pour resserrer vos parties d'un type
mais il existe quand même des capsules
de resserrement intimes
vous avez jamais utilisé sa non j'adore
mais s'il est facile aussi vous faites
ça mais moi je voulais le faire dans
l'épaisse g chez des week-ends
[Applaudissements]
alors oui c'est quoi la question est ce
que vous êtes choqués non oui les
influences sont être devenu
d'irresponsables or c'est là qu'ils se
sont
dit oui bloquer non oui oui alors guénon
badge pas choquer appartient aussi s'il
n'y a pas de danger pour la santé c'est
pape ne s'est pas tu en sais pas plus
méchant que si un influenceur me
prescrit bdd des pilules pour impôts
pour l'érection par exemple c'est pas
très méchant 1007 c'est là le problème
quelle est
la du produit
darragi alors il parait il joue le liban
ces pilules pour l'érection oui paraît
qu'elles ont en effet eu
oculaires ont fermé les yeux fixés dans
les yeux
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
notre ami mathieu autant fait aucune
morale non seulement ces bêtes c'est
dangereux et c'est irresponsable c'est
dans son jeu qu'est ce que t'en sais
même pas ce qu'on fait onze titulaire
chez les jeunes qui vont à regarder
d'accord et elle elle dit des gosses
adorent jouer bien ça m'a trompé car
c'est ma piaule sous-entendu parce que
j'ai un vagin ou c'est la robe de
l'argent ça veut dire que c'est une
incitation à la pédophilie
vous allez hop mais là je vais là où je
veux déjà
[Applaudissements]
perdu mes nerfs et gilles bad est tout à
la fois que lâcher des meccanos merci
c'est un hommage à ce compte est quand
tu dis que ce soit dix ans qu'une jeune
fille de 12 ans à laval 1 comme il faut
ça sous-entend que quand à 30 ans tape
un vagin comme il faut ça veut dire que
quelque part tu as ça tu formates le
cerveau et sa troupe le festival a aussi
mené par rapport aux garçons aujourd'hui
qu'ils vont justement cherché des filles
de plus en plus jeunes avec une égale
absolument avec des bâches en recense
voilà
qu'on embrasse on a mis ça
notamment alors moi je vais pas juste
que jusque géraldine parce que je pense
que sarah fresu allah vous expliquer
quelque chose s est un peu perdu dans
ses explications j'aurais préféré
qu'elle regarde la story avant de la
poster parce que je pense qu'elle a
juste voulu expliquer que au lieu de
faire les exercices du périnée sa
demande il existait c'est un périnée
pour daniel c'est le périmètre
[Applaudissements]
il existait un produit qui existait à la
place de faire ses amis du pays mais
parce que c'est vrai que il est
nécessaire cet exercice après moi ce qui
me dérange c'est de mettre sa toute
petite seconde parce que je suis choqué
il ya quand même un gars qui me donne la
mission jeanne sauvetage
[Rires]
tarif social
sur thalassa
mais je l'adoré c'est très beau bravo tu
créé l'événement ça c'est après les rats
j'aimerais dire à guillaume genton balle
alors très très belle pièce mâles ordre
alors oui alors
terminé la chose qui me dérange c'est
que j'ai pas d'enfants mais si j'avais
une fille de 10 ans qui tombait sur ce
genre de vidéos ça me met très mal à
l'aise pour moi et pour ma fille et elle
a pas besoin de savoir ça c'est plus
tard quand quand elle sera adulte et non
c'est pas des choses qu'on dit à des
enfants si votre fils aimé les raisons
vous trouvez que c'est bien quelle liste
a par exemple ce ma fille ça suit pas ça
ferait jouer si la seule presse qu'elle
suisse et à
gaza à la raison qui nous dit oui madame
moui alors non mais ce que ça a beaucoup
râlé aussi sur les réseaux sociaux parce
qu'en fait s'adresse beaucoup aux femmes
à l'oreille depuis qu'elle s'est
inscrite sur install pas pourquoi sur
les raisons sur stop ça a été un des
chocs et les gens qui étaient quelque
chose mais je me tiens au courant
maintenant et en fait l'essai surtout
pour les femmes qui relèvent de
grossesse oui et ça a choqué parce que
ça culpabiliser
les gens ce que justement les pommes
tombées bien sûr c'est ce qu'ils ont
fait ça pourrait le faire guillaume
je trouve que géraldine va trop loin ce
qui est vrai c'est qu'on reproche
instagram de créer des complexes aux
jeunes à la série que le message envoyé
aux femmes c'est quoi votre mari vous
trombe en fait c'est de votre faute
c'est terrible et on a l'impression -
gérer les noms j'ai rien contre elle est
nulle et à la seule à faire c'est mon
imprimante les influenceurs aujourd'hui
contre un peu d'argent il peut vous
vendre n'importe où guillaume ya très
longtemps qu'on est et kate moss sur un
magazine qui était tout film pareil on
complexe et les femmes
sur le paramédical normalement on
devrait pas paraître l intention des
syndicats d'enseignants
la tension n'est pas mauvaise foi je
répète ce qu'elle dit mais si j'ai pas
tué suzy
sexuelle et sarah à oui mais comme il
l'avait fait que le lifting de
sahraouis mais c'est bien s'excuser au
moins quand on s'énerve pas les
mafias dormael vague et nos amis ouais
j'ai vu à la danse fait que ça de toute
la journée ces phénomènes vague à l'âme
elle a deux passions dans la vie c'est
maeva ghanam et daniel
maury
ses deux salles ces deux salles deux
ambiances mais elle ressemble par bien
des côtés
c'est pour les mois les points communs
de ces gens comme un aléa elles sont
beaucoup de points communs non mais vous
dira qu elle adore dubaï vous adorez
dubaï j'aimerais bien aller pour voir
vous vous prenez pas l'avion donc voyons
voiture
qu'on va te laisser avancer